a lot of people know about your recent
exit of your company and I know you do a
lot of things in business and you're big
on social media but I got to ask you
this first question what was it like the
day you sold the company the wire
cleared and you had that money in your
account what did that feel like from
being a young man who once had a dream
to that moment you saw the numbers in
the bank account so so that's
interesting you're asking that question
because we're
um we're in Monaco we're we're taking a
couple hundred guys in Monaco we're
staying at the Fairmont so everybody is
trying to have a good time people have
no clue we're closing the company the
deal so we go to this restaurant called
Le Luis which is like the main
restaurant three Michelin star right
next to the casino on the Strip you know
it's only five tables or ten tables and
you're eating this food it's a three
four five hour you know dinner that
you're having and I keep stepping away
for one hour I keep stepping away for 30
minutes they're like why is Pat stepping
away but I can't tell them why I'm
stepping away because we're going
through it right now
and then eventually the deal is done the
announcement is made and my wife and I
go to have breakfast together at this
one place in Monaco which is like seven
minute walk from uh uh from the hotel
we're staying at then I'm sitting right
in front of her at this regular you know
friendship breakfast spot that nobody
knows
and we're just talking and it was three
hours of the most unique smile
that we both had on our faces very
emotional a lot of crying a lot of
laughing a lot of a genuine respect and
gratitude for each other to uh have done
what we've done then there was a
different moment with our sales leaders
on what they did to help the company get
to where it was because we would never
be without them the people that were in
that meeting they know how that meeting
went incredible another emotional
meeting and recognizing what Tom did to
help the deal go from beginning to the
end but uh when the money hits the bank
and Goldman Sachs calls you and he says
Hey the money shows the account I mean
listen I've gotten 10 000 auto checks
I've gotten hundred thousand dollar
checks I've got million auto checks I've
gotten 10 million auto checks I've
gotten 50 million dollar checks this was
a real check you know at an incredible
time and and more importantly to do with
with a company where the guy at the top
of that company is the biggest
heavyweight in the insurance industry
doing what he's doing uh Brian with IM
she you know it was a great uh
partnership we had a some of the biggest
private Equity companies that you know
their names that the deal was pretty
much done with one of them one of the
top 10 biggest everyone knows who it is
we met in Miami
um
deals getting done I get a call saying
hey before you finalize the deal are you
willing to meet with these other guys
they want to meet with you I said I have
all I've already met with them multiple
times are you wanting to do dinner sure
they come out we go to Casa D'Angelo for
dinner a two-hour dinner turns into a
five-hour dinner we get in the car it's
me Tom our guys from Houlihan Loki he
says what do you think I said man this
is tough because I love this guy I think
this is a good fit for everybody I think
we win I think they win I think our guys
went clients when everybody wins then we
went back then the offer was made then
we finalized the offer and we all got
rainy figure eggs yes multi multi nine
figure exit yes and
um yeah the rest is history and then
obviously we are where we are today
what's the first thing you guys did when
the check cleared you saw the money
like buy or buy say to your wife feel
that day
you know for me I'm all about
um
I want like the moment I realize I can
compete in something and then you go
through the anxiety of now you know you
can compete in this area how big do you
want to go it's a very interesting
one-on-one moment you'll have with
yourself like when I was first selling
insurance I had no idea how good I could
be in insurance and then at one moment
when this happened this is like May of
2004 had been in it for two years I said
I can really make some money with this
and then it was like do you want to put
in the effort I said I'm all in let's go
and I started going 100 hours a week and
it was we started competing so it's a
beautiful thing when you sit there and
you have a couple I had two people I was
competing with the marketplace uh both
of them had retired in the industry with
massive multi uh nine-figure exits as
well but one of them had done it in his
50s the other one had done it in the 60s
and that was my target you know Vision
100 I always saw the vision and I want I
said I'm gonna give myself 20 years in
this business and I'm gonna go all out
when I'm saying all out I'm talking 100
every week I'm at the office six days a
week if you ask people that are working
in the office and ask them how many six
days sick days people paths taking 13
years they're probably gonna take tell
you one or two so I'm not the guy that
takes sick days during covet I worked uh
every single day except for one Sunday
during covet because it was a very
uncertain time but again going back to
the whole part when you're saying how
this was the first feeling it was is
okay here's was the vision this is what
we cast it it became a reality
How about if the next vision is even
bigger and we're willing to go at the
same Pace now we have more wisdom more
gunpowder better connection better
contacts more moral Authority you know
credibility in the marketplace
what kind of an impact can we make next
and what can this next run look like so
it's an incredible feeling to to say the
least because it validates your teaching
and your philosophy so during the time
if a lot of people said oh he has no
clue what he's talking about oh he's
wrong or he's all about this and he's
all about that
and then the market validates it with
that big of a check then those guys have
to go answer to the people that they saw
that this guy had no clue what he was
doing that's a tough conversation to
have when the first person asks says so
what do you think about what happened
with Pat I just want to record that
conversation to see what the rebuttal is
well you know we always knew but you
know it's bad but I've heard some things
you know that's that's the part that
refuels me even more to go for the next
one because I can't constantly want to
create content for
um many of those folks but uh you know
it's it's a great feeling to say the
least and it's the ultimate Checkmate
you know absolutely to people who would
have otherwise alternated Checkmate is
that you have to say nothing
you know you know how hard it is that uh
imagine when because that business is
cut throat too it's insurance is very
Cutthroat and I was the most hated guy
in the insurance industry for for 15
years they're special and blew up the
brand too yeah I was I was hated uh from
many different angles uh uh you know I
don't look like an insurance CEO I look
more like a security guard I'm not a
four-year degree from Cornell or Georgia
Tech or this or that uh I'm from Iran
I'm Middle Eastern I'm loud I'm a very
pro-capitalism you know or you know
strong opinions and I'm not quite about
it 54 of our agents were women 51 Latino
34 years old so young edgy competitive
Sports minded and we know how to have a
good time people that are in our Circle
they have the time time of their lives
and but that's kind of how it's got to
be you know
thank you